you are a huge football fan yeah I
watched my team last night Patriots I
hear you're a Seahawks fan yes we have a
complicated my wife my wife's from
Seattle so he's all Seahawks and I'm
Patriots and it can get very ugly we get
hairs involved but how high ten sorry
about the Seahawks oh man
I'm a big fan I mean I love I love
watching them play I you know in in I
was there at that Super Bowl to see the
Seahawks Patriots Super Bowl when that
hit got thrown on yard line and yeah
yeah I'm definitely a big I'm a big
Seahawks fan a huge Seahawks fan okay
have you gone - I mean you must get
hooked up because I would think being
Chris Pratt now if you want to see a
game or something you can just make that
happen
um I have some problems because I'll
tell you when I watch I'm living in Los
Angeles and so I take it for granted
then I can just turn on the TV and watch
my team but it happens all the time here
that I know you supposed to get this
like crazy package that's it I always
forget to do that and then I don't see
my aim I hate that when that happens I
got the Sunday Ticket cuz it was
important to me I live down a
Californian or maybe I'm gonna be on the
road at Lance and they don't always play
the Seahawks games and I got so mad in
fact I got so mad the other day because
I I I'm excited to watch the game I'm
sitting in front of my TV I turn it on
the NFL Sunday Ticket the NFL Sunday
Ticket no games are wrong and I was like
you got to be kidding me I called
DirecTV get an answering machine at
first and I'm I'm already boiling mad
you know it's like person press 1 if you
I was like person you're already a
DirecTV person and they were like we
will now transfer you to a person I was
like you know I was so mad and the lady
says hey you know this is Dolores thank
you for calling DirecTV I was like
listen Dolores cut the crap I'm not
getting it I don't know what this ticket
Sunday tickets a couple hundred bucks
I'm not getting a single game and I know
you black it out sometimes because of
whatever rules you have but I'm not
getting a single game on your Sunday
Ticket and she was like sir it's
Saturday
now it's like Dolores I'm really sorry
but I just swore at you yeah
and they record those phone calls yeah
so whoever you are Dolores if you're I'm
sorry yeah did you ever tell you would
know at any point in the conversation
did you tell her who you were um yeah I
had to say it over I don't think she I
don't know if she put it together or
whatever or if she recognized me but I
would I was like my name is Chris Pratt
and I had the NFL Sunday Ticket ma'am
yeah and I'm and I'm not Chris Pratt
good luck releasing this tape
you